[Music]
all right what's up party people free
guy hey get your free guy we are talking
about the honest trailer for free guy
today uh i'm here with lon and danielle
per usual we'll give you our behind the
scenes thoughts on the film show some
cut jokes and stuff uh take questions if
you got any and then tease you with next
week's honest trailer you know the deal
um not too complicated like
like this movie uh it's just pretty to
me it's very mid uh it was i i was i
enjoyed it i was entertained i saw
nothing
new or unique uh it said about games or
or action comedy in general just like a
i'll call it a good pixels
good pixels oh good pencils like okay
these are people i like doing the things
that i like seeing them do
but like you know it's just uh it got
the job done it got in and out and i
can't hate it i can't love it but what
do you guys think about um uh free guy
did it did it tickle you any any
differently
yeah it was fun like was it it was a fun
little nice uh god that sounds so
condescending when i say it that way
it's okay to be fun tonight yeah like
holiday movie you know it was ryan
reynolds being meta that's a thing that
he loves to do
um and then being charming and all that
stuff little rel being amazing as per
usual
um gosh i can't remember the name of the
actress from happy death day but she was
also she was great yeah like you said
it's all the people doing the stuff you
like them to do um watching them do it
and you talk about jody comer
rudy comer the main the main lady
she's not from happy death day she's
from killing she's yeah she's a
millionaire
everyone oh
yeah she's the lady from the last duel
[Music]
you're thinking of jessica roth i
believe from from happy death yeah yeah
i never forget a coma are you are you
guys killing you fans i mean that show's
incredible
i'm not a big fan but last duel she was
in last year which i did see so nice but
yeah no like everybody's charming
everyone's fun um taika is clearly
having the time of his life
uh clearly like having so much fun and
yeah no i agree it's like uh good pixels
mixed with um
you know uh not so great oh gosh you can
tell my memory's going this morning um
the the uh really good show on apple tv
mythic quest mythic quest oh
i haven't seen that but oh wow you would
really like it see that's exactly what
i'd like from something like this which
is it's very insightful about the world
of video games and the people who play
them in that world and i was looking
there are a few really funny moments in
this where they do get there there was
one joke i was pointing out i think even
in my notes where it's like uh the only
jokes that guy the ryan reynolds
character knows are like horrible
offensive racist jokes because that's
what kids tell each other when they're
playing games and like i wanted more
you know insightful funny things about
the experience of playing these games
and it just kind of feels like
you know the the least they had to do to
get the movie going you know it's like
it's like the minimum viable movie
product you know like it it's got enough
action and enough almost jokes and and
fun beats and stuff for a trailer and
effects and it's like you feel like
you've seen a movie
but there's no real there there there's
not that much going on yeah really very
clever there's something interesting
about like a a comedy take on like an
xbox or something where it's like a
woman who's in love with an ai construct
that her boyfriend designed or something
like like there's the core of something
interesting you can make build an action
comedy out of but you're right i think
where it falls short is the
satire or parody of the games industry
it definitely shows that it came out
during 2016 and when it only goes as
deep as like you know the people in game
are actually losers who sit in their
mom's basement yeah their mother for for
more uh hot pockets like like it's so
sure but also like that joke has been
made uh a million times since uh since
the script sold and i don't think they
updated anything for first even before
that it was like those those jokes and
bits were hacky in the mid-teens even
when this script was written like it
just needs to be more specific to this
world and not just like yeah you get
what games are like they say noob a lot
yeah the kids love games
yeah
it's like i think yeah it's it's an
action comedy but
not really any thrilling action you
could point to the action is like enough
to to make you feel like you saw
something but not really anything and
not really a lot of very funny stuff
it's just like enough but there's
no he's still skating by on on on that
charm well it is a red notice i mean so
you're saying yes we have a first
question from may uh we'll pepper them
throughout actually i may ask is it is
it red notice 100 this is this is a red
notice and i'll give you yeah okay it's
got it's got basically they don't go to
a gala event there's a lot of there is
getting out of a vehicle and like a cool
outfit so that's satisfied but they
don't actually go to a gal event but i
think it satisfies every other we end up
in a jungle there's a lot of there's a
lot of this was obviously shot in a
green screen room that they're then
projecting a background on we've got a
lot of like comedy adjacent banter and
we've got a lot of like action adjacent
sequences like oh i'm gonna run and get
away or like oh we're gonna fight over
this gun briefly but not what you'd
consider
a full
action sequence and and this is maybe
the defining characteristic it's broken
up into a lot of like mini missions like
we got to do this heist and then we got
to go get this drive and then we've got
to go here to do this thing and it's
like that that broken up quest mission
video game style like here's our next
task fetch quest that's the heart and
soul of a red nose but does it
complicate at all the fact that he pulls
out um you know captain america's shield
and a lightsaber does that make it a
force awakens
i think a a a red nose and a reference
movie we you and i have had this
discussion a few times there is there is
overlap there is overlap between these
categories you can have a red notice
with never forget red notice itself has
reference indiana jones
right so like
we're
there's always a little bit of a bleed
over but i i don't think this is a
reference movie i think that stuff is
mainly at the very end i think this is a
red notice with like a little hint of
reference at the end there this feels
like a please clap to me but
it was a definite please clap moment
yeah i'm really excited to see uh no way
home um
at home uh to see if it's just awkward
pauses when the audience was clear
where's that one there's one clip that
is now like leaked everywhere where when
it's when andrew garfield first comes
through the portal yeah and
to to their credit the actors are giving
it they're really playing it like real
like i need a minute to gather my
thoughts about how to respond to this
guy being spider-man but not the
spider-man that i know and like zedey is
doing great she's a very good actress
but it is the longest pause imaginable
it is so long
you have so long to be like say
something you gotta stem j react to this
please
mj you're killing me you want to take a
battle on jump in here something give me
something
give me lola what what are we doing yeah
like everybody like there's a grandma in
the background too like the the ned's
grandma's there and it's like she's
gotta say something somebody has to say
something that should be an option like
like director's commentaries like uh
slavering fanboy commentary just like
there was a tweet thread where a guy
like reverse engineered uh laugh tracks
this week did you see that on twitter i
was like they should have on home video
like an option to put like a cheering
crowd
while you're watching they laughed at
all the jokes you know and like tell the
people which year was the big exciting
moment and like three people were
jumping in they were all discussing and
it's like none of these guys have
realized that they just reinvented the
laugh track wow what's old is new um all
right well let's uh let's watch
something that's a little old and a
little new and roll the honest trailer
for frigay
[Music]
you've seen ryan reynolds quip his way
through three assassin adventures two
heist adventures and one what if ghosts
were also cops adventure this is a joke
hilarious
now before you see him quip his way
through a time travel adventure see ryan
quip where you've never seen him quit
before
in a video game yeah she's good and i'm
fine too thank you for asking okay fine
in a cool video game
uh
uh
take a couple of questions or comments
here adam halpern writes like free guy
thought adam project was meh haven't
seen the adam project have you no i
haven't i've never
so sean levy uh directed adam project
he did directed free guy too three guy
and a project and now they're working
together a third time on deadpool tray
deadpool three yeah uh well how do you
think how do you feel given your free
guy experience with uh uh that pair of
sean levy and ryan reynolds doing
deadpool 3.
excited
psyched
well it's just like i i already know
what the movie's going to be or i have
an idea i'm at this point more
interested to see how they integrate
that in with the mcu than like what i
know with all the jokes and all the
beats and stuff are going to be
um
you just kind of know it but i i that
for me holds more interest than like um
ryan reynolds making another teabag joke
or like drinking his own like gin again
is
like
me what me watching and seeing how they
even though even then it's just gonna be
him making meta commentary on like you
know superheroes sure whatever
sure yeah i mean yeah i'm i'm bummed by
this i think he's he's uh like i don't
hate sean levy movies i feel like like
that first night at the museum is fine
and real steel i think it's pretty good
but um
it i i feel like it should be an
action-oriented director making deadpool
like to me deadpool so much of it is
it's not just quippy quippy funny
meta it is that but it's it's also these
are action movies and the first deadpool
the action is part of what's cool i like
the second one too but the action scenes
are like a big part of what make those
movies cool i think it's the comedy and
the action and this feels to me like
they they're thinking of it as just a
comedy because every guy the action is
not impressive like i don't
it it barely even qualifies as an action
movie honestly it's much more of a
comedy yeah and
like i don't know to me that that's sort
of about i know that they're not you
know it wasn't like we were going to
have you know john woo was going to come
back and make the dead three but like it
would be nice if it was somebody who had
some more chops in that
in that yeah it's too bad they had that
like the falling out because didn't the
john wick guy do the first deadpool yes
yeah david leach yeah right
yeah i don't know that seems like a good
fit
don't worry at the end of the day uh
marvel directors don't direct their own
action scenes anyways there's a team of
people uh in a server farm working on it
right now whatever that actually is
and i get that and like look i'm gonna
see deadpool 3. no matter what you know
like i said i'm not saying this is like
death of the franchise i'm just like
this to me is like oh well they're
definitely not taking this in a
direction it's like a david yates doing
another harry potter movie like okay
yeah i know yeah
um all right i would have hoped somebody
with more action chops like if you're
ever gonna bring joe carnahan in to do
an mcu movie
all right let's keep going they're not
going to do that
welcome to free city an online
multiplayer world that's one part gta 5
one part fortnite and that's where the
references stop because the script is
from 2016.
[Music]
inside it's a world full of sentient
npcs trapped in a loop of violence
suffering and sexual exploitation but as
awful as that sounds it's based on an
even worse idea
it's essentially a fishbowl game people
aren't playing it they're they're
watching it grow so yeah taco made some
changes no one's dropping 60 bucks to
play small talk simulator
it's like my tongue and a baby with a
sunrise okay 30 bucks
lesser actors transform their looks or
personality for a role but when your
people's former sexiest man alive you
just keep doing variations of ryan
reynolds until they stop paying you for
it and guy is one of ryren's more
lovable recent deadpool so pause like we
should we should discuss uh ryan
reynolds at this point because uh
jeffrey elden had an interesting
question um how close is ryan reynolds
to
uh getting uh to a chris pratt level of
overexposure and will the world turn on
him too i would say those are two
different questions yeah well go ahead
danielle uh the world did not turn on
chris pratt because of wilbur exposure
well i'll just leave it there
yeah because of over expo well i think
maybe the over exposure led to more um
to a more thorough uh
yeah examining of like wait what's this
guy's deal and then that but
uh because if he had just popped up you
know once every three years in the
guardians movie no one would have been
like huh
what'd you say um that said um i think
ryan reynolds look for what for our
experiences uh with him and from every
uh everything we
uh have heard he's a lovely canadian man
like there isn't uh
whatever darkness is there uh probably
would have been uncovered by now um
but but he can still get overexposed or
it can still be like yeah you have like
one gear or two gears as an actor and
you just keep cycling back and forth i
don't i mean i i i honestly feel like
ryan reynolds is as much victim here as
he is to blame like there are a narrower
and narrower range of movies being made
and roles for guys like him and i do
think he's made movies where he's done
different stuff and been interested the
nines is one that comes immediately to
mine which is a weird ass movie but he's
going for it and not just doing ryan
reynolds stuff the whole time like he
like he's on the pizza place sitcom
still and um and i so i don't
necessarily think he only has this one
mode i think this mode works really well
and if you had somebody who's gonna cut
you checks of this size to come back and
do the thing that you know works really
well i don't know if most of us would
say no and like a lot of a-list actors
it's like okay i'm gonna do one for me
and then one for you know the money and
for him he's doing uh you know one for
the money and then uh starting a
billion dollar gin company so
he doesn't need to do anything but i
mean it's obvious that these are the
kinds of projects that he's you know
everybody would take a meeting on and
wants to make and he can he has his
choice of who to work with and where to
go if he wants to make something like
the atom project or free guy and if he
wanted to make something else like the
nines he'd have to like make a deal to
make that happen
right yeah yeah yeah
yeah well so i don't know if we've
reached
overexposure
per se because i mean
he's been doing this people people
freaking love this guy yeah this was a
huge movie oh yeah
it's but it's a difference of like real
overexposure and like people on twitter
are sick of you which i think like maybe
that's a bellwether for things to come
but um but even that on twitter i was
like i don't love sean levy as the
deadpool 3 guy and people were like how
dare you so like i don't think i don't
think we're at the point where reynolds
levy are on people's nerves yet at all
yeah honestly it's just uh i think
residual just like red notice uh
distaste
in people's minds and hearts is like oh
red notice
[Laughter]
but in my mouth he'll climb the ranks of
the free city leaderboard by
role-playing as a killer cop all to
impress the girl of his dreams millie in
the game she's a super hot ass kicker
with attitude but outside she's still
jody comer so same diff then there's the
two programmers mouser and keys mouser
and keys come on did this guy name him
you seem
adjective keys invented a way to put a
real version of his crush in a video
game and we're all just going to pretend
he wasn't planning to [ __ ] it one day
and making life difficult for everyone
is studio boss antoine who's like taika
watiti wants all the success and
threesome start going to his head
lonnie put in his draft uh um you called
him goblin mode type of white
and i'd like to pull paul the audience
is goblin mode like a
widely enough known term that people
would understand you were like making a
joke and not like he's not a goblin what
are you saying
are we all familiar with goblin mode in
the chat sound oh you thought i would
say like he would like he's an actual
goblin yeah like people just wouldn't
understand oh it is a very
it it's uh it's a very twitter reference
yeah i love it i would always i will
keep it a goblin mode joke
yeah
at this point we all just have to give a
give up and go goblin mode but i think
that that's part of um that's kind of
like an extremely online thing to say or
do and i always wonder like how much we
should
reflect like the the the bleeding edge
of like internet weirdness and how much
we are talking to like a relatively
normal adjusted person who likes i feel
like goblin mode is right at that
it's right on that point of like the
it's been it's been percolating on the
internet for a month month and a half
and now we're starting to get those like
are people becoming social goblins like
like the atlantic that's gonna start
publishing you know like
slate.com is gonna have goblin mode
references in a few weeks i think we're
almost at that breakout moment yeah
pretty soon hillary clinton is gonna say
trump went goblin mode with that one
it's coming it's gonna happen yeah why
kanye why did you bring this to us
sorry uh all right um
no shame in going goblin mode it's been
a it's been a long couple years uh all
right let's keep playing
what you talking about
say what you will about free guy but
good for these two they've come a long
way since their last movie together i
want to see it
fine
i totally forgot that that was
the biggest game streamers of today with
the gamer speak of 20 years ago boot the
trash ass noob and bannon for life the
trash ass noob am i right hello kids
from the trolls in free city trolls with
cameos by jacksepticeye pokemane ninja
uh that one and that guy and uh pass
unless channing tatum i recognize him
but the best surprise of all is more
ryan reynolds stealing the show is
hollywood's most evil creation yet as
they finally found a way for a-list
actors to outsource the steroids to
someone else's body you can put the
protein shake down now chris and hugh
and chris and tom and chris and in a
world dominating
i thought that was uh
that was pretty cool i actually i i i
clapped when i saw large fine runnings
that was my favorite part of the movie
wow i think by far um was the uh that
was like the one sort of almost smart uh
uh commentary on the games industry and
stuff like that that they had made this
totally unfinished thing that they'd
launched anyways and like i don't know i
i thought that was like a very clever uh
character
also observation also semi good action
scene was was uh was that whole section
um you clapped for your large ryan's son
i clapped for my large friends he was
like that's funny
yeah absolute unit yeah yeah i liked it
i i thought that that was a good uh
final boss i guess um yeah i mean like
that
that is it is a funny beat that he's put
this unfinished element in the game and
and that does have and it is a good it's
a cool looking effect like it has that
uncanny-ness but in this scenario it
like works to its benefit it doesn't
look like they're trying to make it look
real um so i think that words but again
it was the action
you're hoping for a big conflict and i
feel like it doesn't quite
they just kind of throw them around a
little bit and then it's over
yeah you're like i guess there was some
sort of like
matrix training sequence that got cut
out like why why does guy
know how to like how how is he good at
any of this he's a bank teller
well i don't know for me the whole movie
is kind of a uh
kind of a
training sequence right because you go
through and you watch him like learn how
to do all the stuff without actually
attacking people um so yeah i guess i
just viewed the whole movie as like a
training sequence but the stuff he's
doing is like i guess you know if it's
just the game you know he's leveling up
like the number just indicates that but
he is doing you know full martial arts
sequences against people i like that uh
he's a jeopardy
answer like yeah before he's even at
level 100. like jody comer at the
beginning is like get to level 100
before we like please don't waste my
time and then he's like he's already a
national phenomenon at level like 50.
like why aren't you on tv jody comer
you're so freaking out yeah like i
understand the streamers but it did
strike me as funny that like the
local news and stuff that would stop
covering whatever to be like something's
happening on grand theft auto
[Laughter]
oh tornado's coming uh you get in your
shelter i'm not quite there yet folks
sorry a few more years yet
all right your fortnite dance makes uh
thanksgiving amazing news i'm looking
forward to uh my retirement home it's
just all it's just gonna be a lan party
um
and like like a pacific sun wear to like
make me feel comfortable
um okay let's keep playing guys is cheer
for an original movie to crush it at the
box office in this brand new story about
an extremely friendly guy who doesn't
realize he's in a fake world designed
for our entertainment full of background
jokes that tip us off something subtly
wrong where he gets fixated on a strange
woman from the real world that he's only
seen once and his best friend is
designed to keep him immersed in the
reality and he starts slowly getting
curious to try new things and we keep
cutting away to news reports and
reactions from viewers around the world
and he can only escape by getting over
the uncrossable water and past the
horizon while the mastermind throws
every possible kind of obstacle in his
path yessiree any similarities to any
other films are just one of those
coincidences where two writers have the
exact same idea
can we just pick a uh a movie
a good movie from the 90s to steal and
we'll just we'll just pause this show
and we'll go write it and then we'll
just i guess you can just do that now
that'd be great it works very clearly
i didn't even see anybody point this out
like i didn't see this for a while when
it first came out and i didn't see any
like i discovered this organically on my
own while i was watching it yeah so when
i was watching i was thinking lego movie
wow this is so similar
especially the opening 15 20 minutes
with the coffee and the water like that
everything is awesome
playing and then
you hit me with the with the truman show
and it it's it all clicked into place
like scene foresee and something i i
think it's especially glaring with the
cutting away to people watching around
the world and like reacting in real time
like that is such the truman show's
bit it's so memorable the way that peter
weir does it in that movie yeah
yeah yeah um let's remake
dave
okay yeah yeah that's a good one
actually david dave yeah dave with like
a trump style figure would be
interesting well yeah because who's the
heroes you got it you got to pick the
president um yeah interesting uh
all right yeah let us know which movie
we should steal in the comments below
okay sure i think we all know that it's
twitter get cooper hoffman to just
we'll make it a we'll make it a
ghostbusters afterlife
i want to float a cow you're selling me
on this now dangerously selling me on
this
okay keep playing five years apart oh
and in case i don't see you good
afternoon good evening and good night
don't have a good day have a great day
so whether you're looking for more of
the same or the same of more this movie
sure to have something for you that
almost has something to say about the
game industry you said free city 2 was
backwards compatible i was flying almost
has something to say about class
struggle it's like every npc
went on strike and almost has something
to say about ethics and ai even if i'm
not real this moment is but definitely
has something to say about how people
are dumb little seals who only clap for
the things they already recognize if you
love kentucky fried chicken and i made
kentucky fried chicken and i know that
you love kentucky fried chicken why
would i make another restaurant called i
don't know albuquerque boiled turkey eye
peas and sequels that is the thing that
people want i know that sounds like
they're making a critique but trust me
it's a confession
oh it's that thing from that other thing
that i like whoa
awesome
fuzz yeah i do love things
i love yeah i love everyone's a guy
nothing more fun than recognizing a guy
um so two two questions on this uh theme
basically uh well adam halbert says uh
uh the marvel and star wars prop cameo
was the only part movie i hated um what
ip cameo in a movie do you hate if you
have one that you hate or you could go
down the other door uh sharahan sadhu
writes what other ip prop cameo would
you like to see in free guy 2
i mean ready player 1 really did the
whole movie props as video game pro like
i don't
like
it's it's been it's been done i don't i
don't really know if i need to see a lot
more rifts on on that idea yeah what i
would like to see is them just start
straight up integrating dark universe
stuff that never we'd ever got to see
them realize you know like where's
creature from the black lagoon put him
in free guy too
you already know what i'm going to say
we want more egg
more egg
more egg like the cleopatra
yeah you said egg and i was thinking
more ready player one like you're an
easter egg hunter meaning you were a
gunter so i was thinking that was a
gunting reference
of course
my brain goes straight to god
um
yeah i would like it if uh uh russell
crowe came out as his dark universe uh
jekyll mr hyde oh yeah nick fury
or or captain jack aubry from master
commander i'd be okay oh a master
yeah um god what's his name what's the
the jude law's like little book of
specimens
paul bettany paul
stephen
the naturalist yes thank you this is
just a big boat
just because all of a sudden a big boat
yeah there's just like a big you know
like a frigate pulls up
i think uh in free guide too he should
pull
the
benedetta uh um thing out
next time
this is a family show
uh maybe deadpool 3. uh all right let's
keep finishing starring
dammit
can't get out
thoroughly post-modern millie keys keys
keys keys in free guys only people in
l.a are going to get this joke
yeah yeah so look there's 10 million
people in los angeles county that's
enough
some of them will get this um it's a
local radio and l.a is gonna get it
because that ad is is everywhere it's
been playing for as long as i've been
alive um and it's uh it's a
auto dealership called keys and i guess
it's on van nuys boulevard yeah um so
yeah keys keys keys keys on ben eyes i'm
sure every town has their local
thing that they've uh that's definitely
one of the most prominent la like radio
earworms of all yeah right it's like and
it's like am radio i associate with like
my parents listening to like knx 1070
right news radio
and then that commercial yeah um i think
the only other empire carpets is the
only other one i know as well well
there's well you wouldn't get a lemon i
wouldn't have got 11.
that's only orange county though right
did they get those in l.a yeah that's
toyota of orange yeah toyota of orange i
still got those ads and then the um
because i got those in high school the
like cane and abel saga of uh um sit and
sleep oh right yeah
everywhere those are nationwide though i
used to hear howard stern talking about
larry at sitting asleep yeah but you
know your mattress is free yeah yeah
larry and his uh his accountant uh who's
always going crazy because the
mattresses are searching
were they brothers or is that just my
head cannon
are they brothers i always thought it
was just his accountant he was
introducing his accountant okay uh
someone fact check me on that yeah
find out what's going on behind the
things that sit and sleep everybody
okay anyway sorry for that digression uh
let's keep let's keep playing bro code
21 jump down left right a b start street
hugh hackman
coming soon free city 2 bigger
better wait who's that epic voice i
thought we had something special ryan
and funny name
ryan reynolds and the terrific heroical
not just good very great day
ryan you're a funny guy but next time
make it a little less obvious that you
helped write the script he's funny and
he's sweet and he's so handsome he's
also a really cute guy and not just the
face you know but like the whole thing
then let me do it for you
guy
you
are
dreamy also he's like crazy hot oh my
god totally i'd hit those pixels hard
yeah i think there's like an over under
on like four i'd say four is the uh what
to peg it at for how many times people
mention in the film how hot ryan
reynolds is in like his last three or
four movies and in case you're trying to
come back with oh but it's the video
game character it looks exactly like him
he's a video game character and it's an
exact port of rhyme yeah it's like
uncanny valley like creepy that video
game by the way can i just say two
things about the the processing speed at
which they are serving people free city
that game the graphics are incredible
for a multiplayer online like they're
all playing in like 4k
streaming and it looks incredible like
ps5 quality
and
apparently one of the characters who's
interacting with everybody in the middle
of the town has like westworld in their
head like they have a full sentient ai
personality and nobody's just slowing
your game down at all
yeah there's no lag jokes there's no
like oh the
server shards like anyone who played a
mmo rpg for like more than a year would
have had a dozen other easy easy
observations right but i mean like that
scene where he and jody come are eating
ice cream together she's interacting
with a fully formed digital personality
she can't tell that it's human and it's
running in the middle of a video game
and it's like ah that's fine it's not
slowed down like the guys having the the
shootout a block over are definitely
experiencing some lag while that's going
that's a shame uh let's see uh uh let's
see if we had anything cut from this one
i don't think there's too much on there
come on where's the computer science
movie
starring
dead fool
ready player dom
the computer wore tennis shoes jim and
barrett
guys bbf real pixel howry
i'm not your buddy guy
fragging eve
atomic spawn
stranger pings taika dom and magic mike
69
the leg eye movie
well there you go um all right on to the
questions uh levetto asks uh sean levy
said the world needs a comedy with ryan
reynolds and hugh jackman and he wants
to direct it
uh what other comedies does the world
need with two actors teaming up i'm sure
they'll find a way i'm sure they'll find
a way into deadpool 3 to get to get hugh
in there and like a multiverse wolverine
joke it's like
yeah right why wouldn't they yes i
thought that's what the question was
going to be is even like how is
wolverine going to work into deadpool 3.
yeah
but any two uh can you pick any two
comedians you like to see on the
ones of this one's of that or uh oops
we're related or whatever
whatever
i got one because i know one thing i
would really love to see is he's so
funny in game night i'd love to see
jesse plemmons do more comedy and i
think the perfect pairing for him would
be matt damon we've always said there's
this resemblance
it makes perfect sense for them to play
brothers or cousins in something okay uh
so there you go there's my pick jesse
fleming's mandy clemens and david i like
that i go uh
daniel radcliffe elijah wood
you can throw jake lloyd or hayden
christensen in there
just like the the chosen boys all
getting reunited for uh sure to go to a
uh comic con they can play themselves or
why magic macaulay culkin counts
yeah yes yes yeah yeah
by the way did you shoot righteous
gemstones season two i haven't seen the
second season oh there it i don't want
to vlog but an amazing camp yeah so yeah
zoe saldana and tiffany haddish doing a
version of twins
nice
sure
yeah yeah
like the badass
has been rumored for so long yeah but i
think with the with the loss of ivan
reitman i think we're probably saying he
was the main driving force behind the
twins reboot the twins verse
okay uh let's do well with benz do you
know how much money an a-lister like
chris evans makes for a three-second
cameo probably like scale probably the
minimum right i feel like this is a
favor like yeah usually calls his
buddies and he's like hey do you want to
do a vo cameo or a three second thing
like you pay whatever the sag minimum is
or maybe a little more or maybe you give
them like uh
one share of your billion dollar gin
company i don't know i i feel like it
doesn't they don't have to
write them a huge check to it
because they want to i also feel like
with
like there may be with guys like evan
specifically because he is attached to
such a mega property
there may be like
part of his overall deal was like
i owe you three movies two cameos this
that you know right because remember he
came out as a
in thor two writers right like he turns
into him for three seconds he may have
even had like disney because he has one
extra like we can call in chris evans
for something if we need him you know
like i'm i'm sure there have been deals
like that too where it's like i'll stop
by twice like like what whatever julia
louis-dreyfus deal is where it's like
maybe we want you for a scene in this
gotcha yeah you don't have to drop the
whole new deal we just call her and be
like hey when can you come in you're up
yeah
um he's like a little like like a you
ever play like marvel vs capcom where
you'd have like three yes fighters on
your team like you press a couple
buttons and like one of them just runs
in and does a little kick
we're at the point where they could have
called him like that morning and been
like can you give us three hours you
know like we'll send a guy you can keep
your shirt on
yeah
all right we'll close with this uh when
to go uh if he writes
oh not a verifying um it's going to
happen so
what actor do you next want to realize
they're in the matrix slash truman show
slash lego
who's gonna who's a good like uh fish
that realizes you know water is wet uh
uh kind of movie
well they were originally going to do it
i mean will smith is up you know
he's uh he's just done his serious one
which means it's time for him to do
another goofy one he's also good at that
beat that like that men in black
independence day like wait a minute this
world is not what i thought it was and i
am slowly adjusting to this new
information like well smith's a guy who
could really play sell you that that
feat
i come back to this a lot because i
think he's funny but i think paul
giamatti recognizing his entire world
would be really fun
yeah
like what are you talking about this
isn't real you know
okay yeah i'll do mine uh we're going
back to the what who do you want to team
up um is giamatti and wallace shawn uh
together oh realizing that they're in
the matrix but they're not having like a
classy meal over like a couple bottles
of nice wine and then slowly it dawns on
them that like this is not even a real
restaurant they find out that it's the
matrix but neither of them knows how a
computer works so it still just makes no
sense right they don't get it yeah let's
just finish the bottle and go
[Laughter]
done um
all right uh good times uh so i'm sure
we'll be back for free guy too uh this
made all the money and that means you
gotta start a franchise uh wait leave
he's got he's got he's doing stranger
things for now and then i believe he's
got one more thing and then he's got
deadpool three so we're not getting that
two for a while guys
he could hand this one off to a to
another director maybe that's right he
may hand this one off because he's he's
got a pretty full docket at this point
uh in the meantime um yeah uh thank you
for watching we'll be back tomorrow with
sju and next week for a little honest
trailer uh we like to do
uh
annually there's a clue
it's uh yeah you know what's coming uh
but uh we can't wait it's a lot of fun
i'm gonna go wrap that up right now
see you later
[Music]
you